dans une vallée isolée de l'argentine
des chasseurs de fossiles sont sur la
dangereuse piste des dinosaures a tué
ressurgi de notre passé préhistorique
ce ne sont pas les dinosaures qui ont
inventé le meurtre mais ils ont
perfectionné la mise à mort maintenant
les rôles changent le chasseur devient
gibier à chaque nouvelle découverte
les paléontologues en apprennent
davantage sur le secret de l'avènement
des prédateurs
par une sombre nuit du crétacé il y à
125 millions d'années une nouvelle
terreur s'abat sur la forêt vierge
le chasseur est nouveau mais la
chorégraphie tragique a été réglé il ya
bien longtemps
m
une étendue de déserts brûlés par le
soleil au centre ouest de l'argentine en
dialecte local cet endroit a été baptisé
ichi gois la sto c'est à dire la vallée
de la lune c'est ici qu'il ya très
longtemps un cataclysme a provoqué une
ouverture béante à la surface de la
terre mettant à jour un filon de
fossiles large de 300 mètres et long de
80 km
des eaux sont éparpillés partout il n'y
a vraiment que l'embarras du choix
normalement un paléontologue passe des
jours et parfois des semaines à scruter
le sol à la recherche de fossiles
ça se passe généralement dans le désert
où il fait très chaud quand on en trouve
un deux parfois trois c'est une grande
victoire ici richie ou la sto à la
seconde vous pénétrez dans la vallée
vous commencez à voir des fossiles alors
le problème n'est plus de les trouver
mais simplement de décider ce qu'on veut
l'emporter
williams il est venu ici en quête du
saint graal des paléontologues le
premier dinosaure prédateur il y à 230
millions d'années la vallée de la lune
avait un tout autre aspect elle était
recouverte d'une forêt luxuriante et
peuplé de créatures étranges un petit
reptile lourdaud de la taille d'un
cochon parcours et les sous bois en se
nourrissant de plantes
c'était un rack aux oreilles un lent à
se déplacer pas très malin et vieil
habitant de la jungle triazines le rhin
cause rien n'a probablement pas remarqué
l'arrivée d'un nouveau venu avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard
quelqu'un l'a baptisé et aux raptor le
voleur de l'aube
il était carnivore et très voraces des
lots de l'attaqué les pauvres petits
ragots sans rien dans leur nid et les
dépôts c'est avec délectation
il utilisait ses griffes énorme et ses
dents aiguisées
ça lui plaisait bon
le nouveau venu qui possédaient des
dents et des griffes à la mesure de son
tempérament sanguinaire et le plus
anciens dinosaures connues
voici le site où on a trouvé et aux
raptor
c'est l'une des découvertes les plus
remarquables jamais fait tai-chi wallace
tôt nous avons maintenant un aperçu de
la formidable personnalité de ce
prédateur et nous commençons à
comprendre ce qu'il est devenu par la
suite c'est l'expédition d'un jeune
paléontologue paul sereno qu'il la
trouvait mais en fait il a été mis à
jour par ricardo martinez après un mois
et demi de recherches décourager de ne
rien trouver il s'est mis à quatre
pattes et à examiner chaque centimètre
carré de terrain c'est comme cela qu'il
est soudain tombé nez à nez avec et aux
raptor plus petit qu'une main humaine le
crâne des eaux raptor n'est guère
impressionnant mais pour serrano de
l'université de chicago ce petit
prédateur est le point de départ d'
événement étonnant c est aux raptor qui
se rapproche le plus de l'origine
commune des dinosaures le dinosaure
ancestrales pourrait-on dire
plus en tout cas qu aucun fossile
découvert à ce jour il se déplaçait sur
deux pattes et son agilité été
remarquable on ne trouve la trace tôt
qu'un animal semblables c'est pourquoi
il symbolise parfaitement l'origine de
tous les dinosaures la vallée de la lune
s'est montrée généreuse envers paul
serrano trois ans avant la découverte
des eaux raptor son équipe était tombé
sur le squelette le plus complet jamais
trouvé à ce jour 2 ra ra zaurus un
prédateur plus gros est encore plus
féroce quai aux raptor
tout récemment un williams il jubile ans
et son équipe ont mis à jour un ra ra
zaurus bien à eux
le squelette est complet jusque dans ses
détails les plus effrayants
cette semaine même nous avons découvert
ici un nouveau squelette de est rare à
sorrus un superbe squelette avec un
crâne complet la colonne vertébrale est
presque tous les membres
si l'on observe le crâne on remarque les
longues dents incurvé vers l'arrière ce
qui indique que c'était un prédateur
efficaces ils pouvaient solidement
planté cédant recourbé dans sa proie qui
ne pouvait plus se dégager c'est comme
s'ils lui avaient enfoncé des hameçons
dans le corps à cette époque les pattes
avait déjà piloté sous un accord
facilitant les déplacements c'était des
bipèdes et leurs membres antérieurs
étaient courts et munis de gris fait
énorme il pouvait les utiliser pour
maintenir les déchirer leurs proies
moi je me les représente comme des
espèces de tigres qui aurait marché sur
leurs deux pattes de derrière et dans
les pattes de devant red étaient munis
de très grandes griffes ils pouvaient
bondir frappé leur victime l'a déchiré
et éventuellement rebondir en arrière
c'est sans doute la raison pour laquelle
ils ont réussi à régner sur le monde
pendant les 150 millions d'années qui
ont suivi
pour les paléontologues et aux raptor et
ra ra zaurus représente là dedans élèves
des dinosaures ils se tiennent debout ce
qui les éloigne des reptiles ils peuvent
utiliser leurs pattes de devant pour
commettre leurs méfaits
ce qui frappe tout d'abord chez ses
premiers dinosaures prédateurs
c'est l'évolution vers une espèce de
bras qui peut saisir quelque chose ce
n'est plus une pattes de devant qui sert
uniquement un marché l'animal est devenu
bipèdes
il possède une sorte de main munis de
griffes avec un push admis opposable aux
autres doigts en devine qu'il pouvait
attraper une proie tout en courant et
aux raptor et ra ra zaurus ont dû
terrorisé la même forêt il y à 223
millions d'années on a trouvé leurs
fossiles dans les mêmes sédiments de la
vallée de la lune la taille et la forme
des eaux raptor était plutôt banal mais
ra ra aux russes semblent annoncer les
monstres à venir mesurant 5 mètres et
pesant 250 kilos peu de proies devait
pouvoir lui résister il possédait la
caractéristique des prédateurs qui
s'annonce une mâchoire très puissante
erazo russe a eu la mâchoire inférieure
flexible elle comporte une petite
charnière dans le milieu qui devait lui
permettre de la refermer solidement sur
une proie en train de se débattre
r un réseau russe a transmis cette
remarquable mâchoire tout au long de la
ligne et jusqu'aux plus imposant de tous
tyrannosaurus rex
la vallée de la lune si riche en
fossiles a offert un autre superbe
cadeau à l'expédition
il lui permettra de mieux comprendre le
monde ancien des premiers dinosaures
il s'agit du squelette en parfait état
d'un rat cause rien
l'un des malheureux reptilien carrara
jorus dévorer sans merci
je pense que personne n'avait encore mis
à jour à ce que l'aide de raco sauriens
aussi bien conservé c'est un spécimen
remarquable aucun os ne manque et tous
sont en bon état
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel et sa
position est parfaite on dirait qu'il
est couchée sur la table de dissection
c'est incroyable comme tout est là sur
ce spécimen jusqu'au griffe au bout des
doigts voici par exemple une griffe qui
s'adaptait au doigt comme ça c'est la
seule chose casser on pense que l'animal
ressemblait un peu à un cochon il avait
l'habitude de creuser pour trouver sa
nourriture ses griffes importante
devrait l'aider à déterrer des racines
et des plantes
le monde dans lequel les dinosaures ont
fait leur apparition n'était pas un
endroit tranquille
ils étaient dominés par des animaux qui
subissaient des mouvements évolutif
différents
il y avait par exemple l'étrange dit
métro dont portant une voile sur son dos
me reptiles mammifères
ces reptiles malien était plus gros plus
féroce et beaucoup plus nombreux que les
premiers dinosaures
il devait sans aucun doute leur disputer
leurs proies
les fossiles de reptiles malien abonde
également dans les sédiments rouge de la
vallée de la lune et il pose une
devinette aux paléontologues
comment sont apparus les dinosaures quel
mouvement évolutif leur a donné le
départ
cet animal le sino donc est l'un des
reptiles maliens qui ont joué un si
grand rôle dans l'origine des dinosaures
c'est eux qui auraient dû dominer le
monde terrestre par les dinosaures
il s'était déjà presque transformé en
mammifères et puis ils disparurent ils
ont laissé derrière eux de vrais
mammifères mais tout petit et qui ont
passé des millions d'années à éviter des
dinosaures pour survivre les dinosaures
qui auraient dû être des reptiles à
l'esprit laon ont dominé complètement
leur environnement écologique pendant
150 millions d'années
il y à 210 millions d'années pendant les
derniers jours du trias le monde
changeait des tueurs petit et agile se
multiplièrent et envahir ce qui était
alors le super continent danger
on a retrouvé storico aux russes dans ce
qui est aujourd'hui le brésil stains
tarsus en afrique du sud et son cousin
très proche c'est l'office en amérique
du nord
figé dans la mort et dans le temps des
douzaines de fossiles de ces petits
dinosaures fut retrouvée au nouveau
mexique en 1947 adultes adolescents et
très jeunes animaux enterrés ensemble et
formant une espèce de mosaïques
primitive
on
les paléontologues continuent à extraire
avec précaution des rochers de gosses
trench les restes des plus vieux
dinosaures d'amérique du nord
nombreux dinosaures petit mais dangereux
comme celle office représente la relève
de la garde
à la fin du trias il était rapide féroce
et allait rapidement établir leur règne
les descendants des eaux raptor et des
rares à horus avait gardé le goût de la
bonne chère des dinosaures séparés par
des millions d'années et dans la forme
la taille et le poids pouvait varier
considérablement se transmettait malgré
tout le même instinct sanguinaire
il faut quand même noter que chez les
dinosaures seuls les théropodes groupe
comprenant les cellules aux ors et les
carnot d'or était carnivore
quels sont les traits distinctifs de
tous les tueurs du trias du jurassique
et du crétacé il se dandinent sur des
pieds griffu ont une longue queue un
thorax et 3 de petits bras mince pour
attraper leurs proies et une tête très
particulière qui était leur arme la plus
redoutable avec sa formidable mâchoire à
double charnière
c'était pour parler comme darwin un cas
typique de succès engendrant le succès
ou si vous aviez le malheur d'être du
côté des proies un cas de terreur
engendrant la terreur
même si le modèle de base demeure est le
même l'évolution permis à diverses
espèces d'apporter différents
perfectionnement à leurs méthodes de
survie
certains devinrent des animaux les plus
légers à jamais avoir parcouru la
vieille terre c'était des dinosaures qui
ressemblaient à des autruches
on les a appelés les ornithologues mus
ces dinosaures autruches poursuivait le
très petit gibier les arts insectes leur
vitesse de pointe atteignait 100
kilomètres heure il y à 125 millions
d'années une nouvelle famille de
dinosaures carnivores fait des débuts
remarqués
on ne les a découverts que récemment il
s'était consacré à perfectionner chacune
des armes mortelles que la nature avait
mis à leur disposition
on a assez peu de détails sur ce qui
s'est passé au début du crétacé
les fossiles de cette période n'ont pas
encore dévoilé tous leurs secrets
mais en 1991 jim kirkland paléontologues
de la dina machine society de l'ugta a
mise à jour un dinosaure appartenant à
cette époque
baptisé utah raptor du nom du lieu de sa
découverte
il mesurait 7 mètres de long et peser
plus de 500 kg il était muni d'une arme
redoutable des griffes de 30 cm de long
tranchante comme des rasoirs et actionné
par une espèce de ressorts dans cette
cavité la été fixé un tendon très
puissant qui passait sous le pied et
rejoignez la cheville
quand l'animal utilisait sa griffe le
temps dont la rabattait vers le bas lui
faisant faire un arc de 180 degrés
autour du pied et vu la longueur de la
griffe elle pouvait de cette façon
provoquer une blessure profonde et
n'oublions pas qu'il agrippe est sa
proie avec les pattes de devant ils
devaient se servir des pattes arrière à
la façon d'un chat et les projeter pour
déchirer sa proie à une fois par seconde
ou une fois par seconde et demie à
chaque fois ils pouvaient faire des
blessures de plus d'un mètre
vraisemblablement entre les côtes de
l'animal après plusieurs assauts de ce
genre le ventre de sa proie devait
s'ouvrir comme un accordéon et ses
viscères s'échapper le repas était prêt
utah raptor était particulièrement
féroce
utah raptor engendra une ligne est
baptisé les drom ezzor il se mr la
terreur pendant le reste du crétacé
c'était des tueurs à griffes comme diego
nick us et velociraptor mais en quelque
sorte il semblait suivre le chemin de
l'évolution à l'envers quand on
s'interroge sur le mouvement évolutif
on note des choses très intéressantes
utah raptor peser 500 kg au début du
crétacé à la fin du crétacé véronique us
ne pèse plus que 50 kg et velociraptor
également ils deviennent de plus en plus
petit si on observe d'autres familles
comme les éléphants et les chevaux par
exemple eh bien c'est tout le contraire
c'est un parcours tout à fait
inhabituelle qu'ont suivi ces familles
de leur nez au genre qu'est-ce qui peut
compenser chez un prédateur qui veut
survivre une grande perte de poids et de
taille
il n'a qu'une solution développée larmes
la plus dangereuse de toute
l'intelligence le drôme et aux hordes y
est monique us ou griffe terrible a
révolutionné l'idée qu'on se faisait des
dinosaures encore récemment les
imaginait sous la forme de créatures
pataude diatonique us était visiblement
bâti pour la vitesse et multipliez ça
dangereux efficacité en chassant en
groupe
velociraptor la star féroce de jurassic
park le posséder sans doute pas la
redoute à l'intelligence qu'on lui prête
dans le film il était cependant assez
rusé pour chasser de grands dinosaures
un étonnant fossiles découverts en
mongolie montre velociraptor et proto
ceratops emmêlé dans un combat mortel
c'est ici au canada alberta que le vrai
génie du crétacé est apparu un animal
dans le cerveau selon les critères de
l'époque et est énorme étudié à partir
de quelques dents trop dont a intrigué
les paléontologues pendant des dizaines
d'années
phil cris paléontologues gothard et le
muséum et le plus grand expert mondial
des dinosaures prédateurs
en 1982 on était en train de travailler
dans cette région quand on a découvert
le crâne d'un petit dinosaure carnivore
du nom de trop dont c'est le crâne le
mieux conservé qu'on ait aujourd'hui et
on a appris du même coup que trop aux
dons avait un gros cerveau c'est en fait
le dinosaure qui avait le cerveau le
plus important on a aussi mis à jour une
mâchoire inférieure avec toutes ses
dents ça nous donne une idée assez
précise de trop donc ce petit dinosaure
été rapide
il courait sur ses pattes arrière qui
était longue et fait pour la vitesse
mais comme velociraptor il avait un l'on
doit du côté intérieur du pied qui
s'élevait au dessus du sol et était muni
d'une énorme griffe il devait s'en
servir pour éventrer sa proie
ce dinosaure et est d'un type qu'on peut
rapprocher des oiseaux son intelligence
le rand est particulièrement dangereux
pour ses futures victimes qu'ils
devaient piégé très facilement
mais ni sa méchanceté ni son
intelligence n'ont empêché troodon de
subir le sort de tous les dinosaures à
la fin du crétacé
ils étaient pourtant particulièrement
bien armée pour survivre et la
nourriture était abondante mais ça n'a
pas suffi
il ya 65 millions d'années les
dinosaures ont été balayés de la surface
de la terre et le plus étrange c'est que
même trop dont n'a pas été épargné
la vallée de la lune est l'un des
théâtres où les dinosaures ont fait
leurs débuts encore mal connue toute
l'équipe prépare soigneusement les
spécimens que l'on va transporter vers
le laboratoire
attendez une minute va avoir un problème
mais tu es encore du placo si la vallée
de la lune a offert au dr williams il
des trésors de l'ère des dinosaures
il y a trouvé les traces des premiers
dinosaures carnivores et de leurs proies
au destin fatal mais il reste encore
bien des mystères à éclaircir
oui c'est bien comme ça c'est notre
premier squelette complet de on ne sait
pas encore quoi qu'on pense que c'est un
strict autorise si la vallée de la lune
a une histoire à raconter
c'est celle ci dans le ballet de
l'évolution des formes de vie sur terre
c'est le prédateur qui mène la danse les
théropodes ces bipèdes sanguinaire
possédait des bras muni de griffes des
mâchoires redoutable et une intelligence
aiguisée pour l'époque
cela leur a permis de régner sur le
monde pendant 150 millions d'années
mais l'extinction des dinosaures n'a pas
réussi à détruire à jamais leur
morphologie si particulière non
l'empreinte de ses prédateurs n'est pas
complètement effacé les dinosaures
prédateurs ont simplement pris la voie
des airs
nous